تتعرض إسرائيل لضغوط متزايدة
للتوقف مؤقتًا مع تجاوز عدد القتلى في غزة
10000، نصفهم تقريبًا من الأطفال
وفقًا لمسؤولي الصحة الذين تديرهم حماس
هناك، ولكن لا يبدو أن حتى
أقوى حلفاء إسرائيل قادرين على إقناعهم
بهذا المسار الإنساني
تحدث الرئيس بايدن مع رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو  عبر الهاتف اليوم،
بعد أن أمضى وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني
بلينكين عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في التنقل عبر
المنطقة لإجراء محادثات عاجلة في تل أبيب
والأردن والضفة الغربية والعراق،
اختتم اليوم في
تركيا، ونحن نعلم مدى القلق العميق هنا
بشأن الخسائر الفادحة التي تتكبدها غزة.
على أه الفلسطينيين على الرجال والنساء
والأطفال في غزة المدنيين الأبرياء
قلق مشترك بيننا ونعمل عليه
كل يوم أه لقد
أتحنا للإسرائيليين بشأن الخطوات التي
يمكنهم اتخاذها لتقليل
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين المسؤولون الإسرائيليون
يرفضون أي  لم يكن وقف إطلاق
النار أقل بكثير من وقف إطلاق النار الذي يقول إن ذلك لن
يفيد إلا حماس بعد المذبحة التي راح ضحيتها
1400 شخص معظمهم من المدنيين قبل 14 أسبوعًا
قبل أربعة أسابيع. استمع إلى هذا من
سفير إسرائيل لدى الأمم
المتحدة. لا توجد أزمة إنسانية
في غزة بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحدة والأمم
المتحدة.  سمحنا لعدد الشاحنات
أه التي تدخل غزة الآن محملة بالطعام
والأدوية أن تصل إلى ما يقرب من 100 شاحنة أه
يوميا لذلك لا نرى
ضرورة لهدنة إنسانية
الآن لأنها لن تؤدي إلا إلى تمكين حماس من
إعادة التسلح والتجمع وتمنعنا من
تحقيق  هدفنا هو تدمير قدرات حماس
الإرهابية،
فكيف يتم
استقبال ذلك في جميع أنحاء العالم وخاصة في
العواصم العربية وفي الشوارع
التقى وزير الخارجية الأردني أمان الصفدي بلينكن في نهاية هذا الأسبوع وهو الآن
مع الملك عبد الله في مقر الاتحاد الأوروبي
يحاول الضغط من أجل الحصول على المزيد من المساعدات.
غزة يقول الأردن إنه يقوم بتوصيل
المساعدات بنفسه الآن، حيث قامت قواته الجوية بإسقاط
مساعدات طبية إلى غزة في أحد المستشفيات في
وقت مبكر من هذا الصباح، مرحباً بعودة وزير الخارجية
إلى برنامجنا، هل يمكنني أن
أبدأ أولاً بسؤالك، لا بد أن الأمر استغرق
بعض التنسيق
وموقفاً متعمداً للبدء  إن الإنزال الجوي
إلى غزة هو أحد الإجراءات التي ستواصل
القيام بها بشكل
جيد، لقد تطلب الأمر بعض
التنسيق أه كريسان وأه أه قمنا
بإسقاط الإمدادات الأساسية إلى
مستشفى ميداني كان لدينا في غزة منذ
عام 2009 ومن الواضح أن هذه الإمدادات ستكفي فقط
لفترة طويلة نظرا لضخامة
التحدي الإنساني الموجود وأه
نأمل ليس فقط أن نتمكن من
فعل المزيد من ذلك ولكن أن أه أه كلنا
في هذا في المجتمع الدولي
نجتمع معًا للضغط أه
لتوصيل الإمدادات الضرورية  أه أه
غزة لأنه على عكس ما أه
إسرائيلي قال في الأمم المتحدة أه
هناك كارثة إنسانية وأعتقد أنه إذا
كان لا يرى ذلك لا يمكنني
تفسير ذلك إلا بالقول يبدو أنه
لا يرى الفلسطينيين  البشر
يتحدث عن 100 شاحنة عندما كان المتوسط
قبل بدء هذه الحرب الكارثية
حوالي 500 شاحنة في اليوم وبعد ذلك
لم يكن ذلك كافيا لذلك مجرد القول بأنه
لا توجد كارثة إنسانية في غزة
يتحدث عن العمى الكامل أه
لهذا الشخص عن  أه فيما يتعلق بما
يحدث في غزة ولكن من الواضح أيضًا أن ما
يقوله لا يتطابق مع واقعنا
لأنه من الواضح أنه كان عليك
التنسيق مع إسرائيل، لذلك
كان على الجيش الإسرائيلي والحكومة الإسرائيلية
الاعتراف بوجود
كارثة إنسانية مهما حدث
سفيرهم لدى الأمم المتحدة
يقول حسنًا أعني أننا نود أن نرى
الاعتراف يترجم إلى
عمل فعال مؤثر على الأرض
أه الناس يموتون من
القنابل الإسرائيلية لكنهم يموتون أيضًا من
قلة المياه نقص أه أه
دواء  أه الوضع الخطير للغاية
في المستشفيات حيث
لا يعمل الكثير منها ببساطة بما يتجاوز الأساسيات
الأساسية أه لذا أه إذا
كان هناك إقرار، نود
أن نرى ذلك مترجمًا بشكل حقيقي أه عمل
يبدأ حتى أه في معالجة
الوضع الكارثي الذي
لدينا في غزة يا وزير الخارجية أنت
مع الملك عبد الله في أه مقر الاتحاد الأوروبي
ما الذي تمكنت من استخلاصه
منهم من حيث
توصيل المساعدات الإنسانية بشكل أقوى أخبرني ما
هي المهمة للأردن هناك
في بروكسل  صحيح
[موسيقى]
الآن حسنًا، لقد وصلنا للتو كما
قلت جلالة الملك هنا لقد
التقينا للتو مع رئيس الوزراء البلجيكي
التقينا مع الأمين العام لحلف شمال الأطلسي
أه غدًا ستكون هناك اجتماعات في
الاتحاد الأوروبي ورسالتنا واضحة  وبسيطة
هذه الحرب على غزة يجب أن توقف وقف إطلاق النار
هو واجب توصيل
الإمدادات الإنسانية الكافية والمستدامة هي
مسؤولية واجب إنساني ناهيك عن
التزام قانوني من قبل إسرائيل
كقوة احتلال أه فهذه هي
الرسالة التي عليها'  نحن نعمل ومن
الواضح أننا نحاول وضع الأمور في
سياقها فيما يتعلق لسبب وجودنا هنا وأن
السبيل الوحيد للخروج من هذا
الكابوس أه هذه الكارثة هو أن
تتوقف الحرب واه احتياجات الغازين
الذين كانوا يعانون  حتى
قبل أن تبدأ هذه الحرب يتم معالجتها ومن
ثم ننظر جميعا كيف يمكننا أه الوصول إلى
وضع حيث حدث ما
حدث لن يحدث مرة أخرى وهذا لا
يمكن أن يحدث إلا من خلال خطة سلام
من شأنها أن تفي بحقوق
الفلسطينيين في الحرية وسوف تعالج
المخاوف الإسرائيلية أيضًا ولكن فيما
يتعلق بالسلام، من الواضح أن الضفة الغربية
التي بجوارك
هي جزء من الضفة الغربية المحتلة، ومن
المفترض أن تكون جزءًا من دولة فلسطينية
الآن. هناك شيئان يحدثان:
المستوطنون والجنود،
أنت تعلم أن هناك 150
يموت الفلسطينيون وفقًا
للسلطات في الضفة الغربية ويتم
نقلهم بعيدًا عن أراضيهم في
بعض الحالات عدة مئات، هل
تعتقد أن هناك خطة متعمدة كما
يعتقد الكثير من الناس أن المستوطنين
المسؤولين بشكل أساسي عن
الحكومة  يريدون، تحت هذا
الغطاء، كما تعلمون، إنشاء
هدفهم الأيديولوجي الخاص بالحصول على الضفة الغربية
لأنفسهم، هل تعتقد أن هذا هو
الحال أم أنها مجرد تداعيات هذه
الحرب الرهيبة التي
تجري آه إذا جاز لي أولاً أن أقول فقط بشكل
لا لبس فيه ذلك  نحن ضد
معاداة السامية نحن ضد
الإسلاموفوبيا ندين أننا نحذر
منها ونحثنا جميعا على
التكاتف و و و حقا أه
أقول بوضوح أن هذه ليست أه حرب يهودية مسلمة
أه هذه حرب بين محتل
وشعب محتل لذلك أريد فقط أن أوضح
أننا كنا نحذر
من ثقافة الكراهية هذه، فنحن ندين معاداة
السامية بقدر ما ندين
الإسلاموفوبيا التي قالت أه الذهاب إلى
الضفة الغربية أه حتى قبل هذه أه
الحلقة المفرغة من  بدأ العنف والحرب كانت هناك
سياسة إسرائيلية ممنهجة لأه أه قتل أي
تطلع للشعب الفلسطيني إلى
الدولة رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
قال ذلك بنفسه في
الحكومة الإسرائيلية لديك وزراء في الحكومة
بينج فير سمورك الذين
دعوا علناً إلى إبادة
الشعب الفلسطيني  إذن إرهاب المستوطنين وأنا
أسميه إرهاب المستوطنين لأنه
موجود منذ فترة والآن
مع هذه الظروف المأساوية المؤسفة الجديدة نرى
المزيد من ذلك نرى
الناس أه أه
هجمات المستوطنين تتزايد هذا العام بالمناسبة
هو  العام الأكثر دموية للفلسطينيين
في الضفة الغربية منذ أكثر من عقود أه أه
وهذا يتحدث مرة أخرى عن
الغياب التام للآفاق السياسية
وإطلاق أه للمستوطنين
من قبل أعضاء مجلس الوزراء الذين يتحدثون
خطاب الكراهية الذي يغذي أه
أه هؤلاء  الحركة إذا
نظرت إلى الحقائق على الأرض أه
هناك أكثر من 990.000 مستوطن جديد يأتون إلى
الضفة الغربية منذ
2019 أه هي المنطقة C كانت
كاملة أيضا أه أه يتم
انتزاعها تدريجيا من
الفلسطينيين أه التوسع الاستيطاني
مستمر  عدد
التوسع الاستيطاني أو حجم
التوسع الاستيطاني الذي شهدناه في السنوات القليلة الماضية
غير مسبوق منذ عقود
مصادرة الأراضي هو نفسه
التعدي على المقدسات هو
نفسه لذلك أعتقد أن هناك أم مجموعة
داخل أه إسرائيل  أه المتطرفين الصهاينة المتدينين
الذين يدفعون
للمواجهة وهذا لا يساعد
إسرائيل ولا يساعدنا أه
لا يساعد الفلسطينيين لذلك
أعتقد أن على الجميع أن يقفوا على
مسؤوليتهم أه هنا ويتوقفوا عن
هذا النوع من التصرفات و  إذا
انفجرت الضفة الغربية، فأنت تنظر
إلى صراع أوسع نطاقًا
سيؤثر على الجميع لذا
يجب أن
يتوقف